herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
die Radfahrerin die vor wenigen Tagen in
Berlin von einem Betonmischer überrollt
worden ist sie ist leider gestorben
seitdem wird die Diskussion über die
Folgen von klimablockern immer hitziger
denn Aktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation hatten am Tag des Unfalls mit
einer Aktion auf einer Berliner Autobahn
für einen Stau gesorgt und offenbar ist
dadurch ein Spezialfahrzeug der
Feuerwehr am Unfallort einige Minuten
später eingetroffen die Berliner Polizei
stellte deshalb Strafanzeige gegen zwei
klimaaktivisten doch die Aussage der
Notärztin die sehr schnell am Unfallort
war und sich um die Radfahrern gekümmert
hat wirft nun ein ganz anderes Licht
wieder auf die Situation auf die
Umstände wir werden nachher mit Carla
Rochel von der Gruppe letzte Generation
und auch einem Kritiker ihrer Aktionen
dem FDP-Politiker Konstantin coole reden
natürlich auch über Fragen und
Kommentare die wir aber die Social Media
Kanäle bekommen zunächst aber fast mein
Kollege Carsten Behrendt Fakten und
Reaktion zusammen
der Tod der Radfahrerin nach dem Unfall
am Montag heizt die Diskussion um eine
Verantwortung der klimaaktivisten weiter
an auf Twitter nehmen sie manche in
Schutz andere bezeichnen sie als Mörder
und Terroristen aus der Politik der Ruf
nach harten Strafen
wenn Straftaten begangen werden und
andere Menschen gefährdet werden ist
jede Grenze legitimen Protest
überschritten die Straftäter müssen
schnell und konsequent verfolgt werden
so die bundesinnenministerin parallel
zur Debatte läuft die Aufklärung
feststeht Notärzte und Rettungswagen
waren schnell zur Stelle verspätet kam
ein Wagen mit Spezialgerät zur Bergung
von eingeklemmten Unfallopfern der 18
Tonnen schwere Rüstwagen wurde laut
Berliner Tagesspiegel um 8.26 Uhr
alarmiert auf der Stadtautobahn wurde er
in einem Stau ausgebremst an Dreieck
Funkturm die Klimaschützer danach ging
es dann schnell weiter wahrscheinlich
auf dieser Route ein Treffen am
Unfallort um 8 Uhr 19 Minuten statt
idealen 12 Minuten ohne Verkehr das
Unfallopfer war da schon geborgen ganz
aktuell zitiert die Süddeutsche Zeitung
aus einem internen Vermerk der Notärztin
der klimaprotest habe keinen Einfluss
auf die Versorgung des Opfers gehabt
offiziell kommentieren will der Berliner
Feuerwehr das nicht
die klimaaktivisten der letzten
Generation beklagen die Verbreitung von
Unwahrheiten und Hetze in Medien und
Öffentlichkeit
Überschriften
wie Fahrerin das ist einfach überzogen
das ist Hetze und das zieht damit
demokratisch legitimierten notwendigen
Prozess Protest in den Dreck wir haben
uns auf einer Schilderbrücke überhaupt
des Verkehrs befunden und die Polizei
hat dort unter den Verkehr geregelt dass
das Rettungsfahrzeug dann einige Minuten
verspätet kam darauf hatten wir in dem
Fall auch keinen Einfluss
ihre umstrittenen Blockaden setzen die
klimaaktivisten fort währenddessen
laufen in Berlin die Ermittlungen zum
tödlichen Fahrradunfall und zur Klärung
von Schuldfragen
Carsten du bist in Berlin an der
Unfallstelle was sind denn die neuesten
Informationen
die Berliner Generalstaatsanwaltschaft
hat die Ermittlung übernommen und die
spricht von einem sehr komplexen
Sachverhalt das kann man sich auch kann
man gut nachvollziehen weil wir Herrn
eben schon der erwähnten Beitrag wie
viele Ebenen wir ja haben und ich möchte
deswegen gerne mal an der untersten
Ebene anfangen nämlich bei dem
Fahrradunfall hier an dieser Stelle der
hat sich nämlich ereignet genau zwischen
den Fahrspuren da ist die Radfahrerin
gestürzt unter den Betonmischer gekommen
und wir sehen hier eine vierspurige
Hauptstraße jetzt während wir hier
stehen merken wir auch die Autos
wechseln in letzter Minute noch rechts
geht's Richtung Potsdamer Platz links
Richtung Zoo also hier ist richtig viel
los und dann ja dann geht's halt ganz
schnell rechts und links und einige
Radfahrer die ist eilig haben die fahren
auf diesen linken Spuren gerade Richtung
Zoo und nicht hier auf dem Radweg lang
wir haben gerade eben auch mit einem
Radfahrer darüber gesprochen der sagte
nämlich dass dieser Weg halt ein
richtiger Umweg ist der führt da hinten
über Fußgängerampeln weiter er ist aber
benutzungspflichtig eigentlich also wer
hier auf der Straße fährt das ist
wirklich
wirklich sehr riskant ja und es gab ja
dann eine Attacke noch auf den
Lastwagenfahrer von einem Mann mit einem
Messer der ist inzwischen gefasst worden
auch das ist ein sehr unüblicher Vorfall
den wir hier hatten der auch noch dazu
kam der Mann wie gesagt ist mittlerweile
gefasst eine Haftpflicht davor geführt
worden und ist in einer psychiatrischen
Unterbringung und die dritte Ebene dann
das ist die Frage nach der Verantwortung
der klimaaktivisten die sehr weit weg
von hier wir haben es auf der Karte im
Beitrag gerade gesehen ihre Aktion
gemacht haben auf einer Brücke auf einer
Schilderbrücke über der Stadtautobahn
die Polizei hatte sich dazu entschieden
darunter die fahrbahnspuren zu sperren
zwei von drei insgesamt und der
Rüstwagen ist dann eben nicht schnell
genug oder ist zumindest etwas
ausgebremst worden wie stark auch das
ist eben gerade Gegenstand der
Ermittlungen es gibt eine Ermittlung
gegen diese beiden Aktivisten auf der
Brücke da geht es halt um möglicherweise
einen Zusammenhang mit fahrlässiger
Tötung ja und die neueste Entwicklung
eben eine Frage was die Süddeutsche
Zeitung in den Raum gestellt hat dieser
Bericht der Notärztin die gesagt hat
dass das Unfallopfer nicht schlechter
versorgt worden ist durch den späteren
Rüstwagen weiß ich die Ärztin
entschieden hat den Betonmischer vom
Bein vom eingeklemmten Bein der
Radfahrerin zu entfernen fahren zu
lassen so dass dieses Rüstfahrzeug
letztlich für die Bergung nicht benötigt
worden sei das allerdings hat die
Berliner Feuerwehr bislang mit Verweis
auf die staatsanwaltschaftlichen
Ermittlungen nicht kommentieren wollen
ja erstmal vielen Dank für die
Einordnung Carsten denn wir haben ja
auch durch deinen Beitrag gesehen
erstmal wie groß ist Berlin wir sind die
Zusammenhänge bzw ist eben die Frage ob
es überhaupt ein Zusammenhang geben kann
wenn die Dinge so weit voneinander
entfernt sind sag uns aber doch einfach
mal wir haben es ein bisschen im Beitrag
gesehen dass da auch einige dann auf die
Aktivisten zugegangen sind die Proteste
sind ja auch weiter gegangen der
Aktivisten was sagen denn die Menschen
in Berlin zu der ganzen Sache
diese Straßenblockaden die gibt es jetzt
seit Anfang des Jahres im Februar ging
es so richtig los und gerade Menschen
die aufs Auto angewiesen sind die sind
natürlich hochgradig genervt dass sie
morgens wenn sie auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
sind oder teilweise auch abends oder
auch mal mittags dann plötzlich im Stau
stehen das geht nicht mehr weiter da
sagen sie natürlich Mensch wir sind doch
eigentlich auf eurer Seite wir möchten
auch mehr Klimaschutz aber wir sehen
nicht ein dass wir dafür im Stau stehen
und es gibt aber auch viele
Berlinerinnen und Berliner die sagen ja
es tut sich einfach nicht genug in
Sachen Klimaschutz das ist richtig das
muss weh tun man muss es sehen man muss
es spüren das heißt also es gibt da die
zwei Seiten und auch in der Debatte die
wir jetzt erlebt haben dieser in diesem
aufgeheizten auch bis zur Hetze
neigenden Debatte da merken wir dass die
Emotionen dann eben auch entsprechend
hoch kochen und Sachargumente dann
zurücktreten
Carsten vielen Dank für diese neuesten
Informationen und auch für diese
Schilderungen und Eindrücke danke nach
Berlin wir wollen jetzt sprechen mit
Carla Rochel von der sogenannten letzten
Generation und dem innenpolitischen
Sprecher der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion Konstantin coole
erstmal vielen Dank dass Sie beide dabei
sind erstmal die Frage an Carla Rochel
auch in Berlin was ist Ihnen denn durch
den Kopf gegangen als sie jetzt gehört
haben da ist diese Radfahrer nun den
Verletzungen erlegen
mich hat die Berichterstattung darüber
fassungslos gemacht wir gehen auf die
Straße weil wir dieses unglaubliche
Unrecht in der Gesellschaft nicht mehr
hinnehmen können wir gehen auf die
Straße um Leben zu schützen und es ist
immer schlimm wenn Menschen im Verkehr
zu Schaden kommen wenn Menschen im
Verkehr sterben wie allerdings seit
Tagen klar ist haben unsere Proteste mit
diesem Unfall nichts zu tun wir sind auf
der Straße weil wir auf die
Klimakatastrophe aufmerksam machen
müssen weil die Regierungen nicht
handeln weil die Regierung versagen
jetzt haben sie
die haben ja gerade auch den Beitrag
gesehen man muss also vieles abwarten
Kollege Karsten Behrendt hat auch gesagt
das ist ja hochkomplex Zusammenhänge zu
sehen oder eben nicht zu sehen insofern
will ich das komplett erstmal an hinten
anstellen aber sie schreiben ja jetzt
wir setzen die Blockaden in Berlin fort
wir sehen das hier auf Twitter haben sie
geschrieben größtes Risiko für die
Menschheit ist den Alltag einfach
weiterzumachen größte Gefahr ist
hinzunehmen dass die Regierung nicht mal
einfachste Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergreift
so ein bisschen vom Gefühl her würde ich
mal fragen müsste man nicht vielleicht
einfach mal der einfach mal warten der
Pietät vielleicht und sagen jetzt warten
wir erstmal ab wie die Dinge geklärt
werden nach diesem Unfall und dass man
vielleicht dann feststellt es hat das
eine mit dem anderen nichts zu tun das
sieht ja jetzt so aus man macht einfach
weiter
unsere Gedanken sind natürlich bei den
Angehörigen der Verstorbenen wir sehen
aber auch dass uns die Zeit davon rennt
wir haben nur noch wenige Jahre um jetzt
gerade das Ruder herumzureißen uns Rind
die Zeit durch die Finger wir steuern
auf eine drei bis vier Grad heißere Welt
zu Wissenschaftler in schlagen Alarm sie
sagen uns diese drei bis vier Grad
heißere Welt werden wir nicht mal mehr
erleben weil die Welt vorher in
Bürgerkriegen versinkt jetzt ist nicht
die Zeit einfach abzuwarten darauf zu
warten dass die Politik handelt sondern
wir müssen friedlich auf die Straße
gehen wir tun das wir wissen dass es
unangenehm ist wir wissen dass es
unangenehm ist Tag für Tag damit
konfrontiert zu werden was wir alle so
gern verdrängen würden
aber wir wissen auch dass friedlicher
ziviler Widerstand in der Geschichte
schon funktioniert hat und das ist auch
jetzt funktionieren kann und einen
Wandel herbei bringen
dann wollen wir einfach mal hören was
Herr Kuhle sagt
Frau fellser hat bereits Kritik geübt
wir haben das gesehen im Beitrag auch
der grüne Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
hat deutliche Kritik geübt und hat
gesagt alle Protestformen die Menschen
gefährden sind falsch Anton Hofreiter
auch von den Grünen sagt das ganze müsse
lückenlos aufgeklärt werden was sagen
die Liberalen
also ich will zunächst einmal festhalten
dass die klimaproteste die wir an ganz
vielen Orten in Deutschland in den
letzten Jahren gehabt haben einen ganz
wertvollen Beitrag zu politischen
Diskussionen geleistet haben da sind
viele gerade junge Menschen auf die
Straße gegangen und haben sich für ein
ganz wichtiges Thema eingesetzt und
viele Menschen sind politisiert worden
durch solche Proteste und durch solche
Aktionen durch solche Straßenblockaden
wie wir sie jetzt in Berlin
beispielsweise erleben werden all diese
Errungenschaften der Klimabewegung
zunichte gemacht denn hier ist eine
kleine Gruppe die offenkundig auf Gewalt
auf physischen Druck setzt und das führt
am Ende dazu dass Menschen sich von
diesem Thema Klimaschutz abwenden und
natürlich muss man auseinanderhalten die
strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen und die
politische Verantwortlichkeit für die
Gefahren die da entstehen wenn man
solche Straßen Blockaden macht man wird
am Ende rausfinden in einem
Ermittlungsverfahren bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft ob man sowas anklagt
oder nicht aber unabhängig davon ist das
was die sogenannte letzte Generation da
macht Sau gefährlich und ich appelliere
wirklich an sie damit aufzuhören weil
sie helfen weder dem Klima noch der
demokratischen Diskussion in diesem Land
und die Attitüde dass man etwas mit
Gewalt durchsetzen will ist im Kern
totalitär und antidemokratisch und so
werden wir das Klima nicht retten
das sind ja nun deutliche Worte auch
direkt eben an sie Frau Roche was sagen
sie dazu sie sagen selber friedlicher
Protest es tut Not aber wenn es sagen
wir mal gewisse Folgen hat und die
Menschen nicht mitnimmt denken wir jetzt
sagen wir mal an Greta thünberg da gab
es ja sehr viel Respekt und Begeisterung
aber das waren angemeldete
Demonstrationen da hat man vor der
Schule gestanden auf dem Rathausplatz
etc und da ist ja auch sehr viel
Sympathie dafür da gewesen jetzt sind
die Aktionen völlig anders wenn Farbe
auf Gemälde in Museen gespritzt wird
damit Dinge zerstört werden dann
schütteln die Leute den Kopf und sagen
was hat das Ölgemälde mit dem Klima zu
tun ist diese Form des Prozess irgendwie
gerechtfertigt bringt das was und die
Leute wenden sich ab und haben kein
Verständnis dafür ist das also nicht wie
Herr coole sagt ein bisschen
kontraproduktiv dass man die Leute dann
eben nicht mitnimmt und eigentlich die
Meinung die öffentliche Meinung gegen
sich aufbringt
den Menschen ist schon lange klar dass
wir so nicht weitermachen können die
meisten wissen dass wir schon mitten in
der Klimakatastrophe stecken sie
erfahren es selber dadurch dass es im
Sommer so unfassbar heiß wird dass man
nicht mehr rausgehen kann dass die
Flüsse ausgetrocknet sind dass die
ganzen Wälder brennen
diese Menschen wollen Maßnahmen
Maßnahmen wie einen 9 Euro Ticket oder
ein Tempolimit eigentlich spricht nichts
mehr dagegen diese Sachen nicht
umzusetzen wir setzen uns friedlich auf
die Straße wir bilden immer eine
Rettungsgasse wir stehen auf wenn ein
Rettungswagen kommt das ist friedlicher
Protest
und ich finde es sehr wichtig zu sagen
dass auch am Anfang von den Fridays for
future Protesten dort gar keine
Sympathie war die Medien haben darüber
berichtet dass die jetzt nicht mehr zur
Schule gehen wie sollen denn die Kinder
noch lernen wenn sie jetzt an diesen
klimastreiks teilnehmen das kam erst
später und all diese Protestformen die
wir da gesehen haben Demonstrationen mit
bunten schildern Millionen Menschen auf
der Straße
unfassbar viele Petitionen haben am Ende
dazu geführt dass wir ein
verfassungsfeindliches Klimapaket haben
keine Regierung der Welt tut gerade
genug keine Regierung der Welt übernimmt
Verantwortung auch nicht die in
Deutschland und deshalb müssen wir
weiter auf die Straße gehen deshalb
gehen wir auf die Straße weil wir damit
einen Wandel herbeibringen können und
immer mehr Menschen gehen gerade nach
Berlin sind bereit in den friedlichen
zivilen Widerstand zu treten aber Frau
Protest auf die Straße gehen dass Greta
thünenberg Metallbauer auch getan das
ist aber ein bisschen eine andere Form
gewesen und es hat zumindest da die
Möglichkeit gegeben direkt mit der
Politik die ja eben auch kritisiert
worden ist zu sprechen was wir jetzt
beobachten anders als eben bei dieser
sage ich mal Generation tütenberg
Neubauer etc ist dass bei ihnen so ist
das Klimaforscher wie zum Beispiel
multiplativ sozusagen gegen sie sprechen
und eben auch kritisch sind das heißt
diejenigen ihre Verbündeten eigentlich
Klimaforscher sind gar nicht mehr auf
ihrer Seite hören wir mal was motivativ
in ZDF volle Kanne gesagt hat
stellen wir uns mal vor dass immer mehr
Gruppen solche Aktionen machen würden
dann würden wir ja im Chaos versinken
das heißt also es gibt Regeln und es
hört letzten Endes da auf wo entweder
Gegenstände und vor allen Dingen auch
Menschen gefährdet werden und bei den
Aktionen die wir in den letzten Wochen
gesehen haben war das tatsächlich der
Fall und deswegen muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen das ist ein No-Go für mich
jedenfalls ein No-Go und am Ende des
Tages bringt es die Klimaforschung im
Speziellen und die Wissenschaft
vielleicht sogar insgesamt in Versuch
weil nachher wird dann nicht mit
differenziert wer tut dir eigentlich was
und dann wird nachher die Klimaforschung
oder die Wissenschaft in Sippenhaft
genommen und dann haben wir genau das
Gegenteil von dem erreicht was man
eigentlich erreichen wollte
ganz kurz dazu der Zweck heiligt nicht
die Mittel sagt multiplativ
wir werden im Chaos versinken wenn wir
jetzt nicht handeln das wissen alle die
sich damit beschäftigen das weiß der
Großteil der Gesellschaft nur die
Politik ist immer noch nicht bereit zu
handeln
Wissenschaftler in aus ganz Europa waren
letzte Woche in Bayern auf der Straße in
Bayern dem Bundesland was für das größte
klimaversagen in Deutschland steht und
sie wurden dafür eingesperrt jetzt
gerade sind Menschen dort ebenfalls
wieder in Zellen für einen Monat die
friedlich gestern ihren Protest auf die
Straße getragen haben die Wissenschaft
ist sogar bereit sich mit uns dort auf
die Straße zu setzen und sagt selbst die
Regierung haben versagt
gut sie haben aber sogar gerade gehört
dass relativ sich nicht auf ihrer Seite
stellt sondern deutliche Kritik übt das
kann man jetzt einfach nicht wegwischen
umgekehrt Herr Kohle an sie sie haben ja
deutliche Kritik geübt aber sie haben ja
auch gerade eben wir haben alle zusammen
ja auch den Beitrag von Carsten Behrendt
gesehen der Aspekt der heute nun aufkam
die Süddeutsche Zeitung Brüche die
Notärztin sagt eben es gibt eigentlich
gar keinen großen Zusammenhang dieser
Rüstwagen sei gar nicht gebraucht worden
ist dann vielleicht die ja eine Art
Vorverurteilung gewesen sind die
Schuldzuweisung vielleicht da ein
bisschen zu schnell gewesen wenn die
Notärztin ja recht hat
die Unschuldsvermutung gilt bei
strafrechtlichen Ermittlungen immer und
die gilt natürlich auch gegenüber den
Aktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation ich gehe aber so weit dass
ich sage selbst wenn an dem
strafrechtlichen Vorwurf nichts dran ist
dann sind solche Aktionen trotzdem
daneben und ich will einmal sagen was
mich wirklich ärgert nicht ärgert dass
wir Stadt über Klimapolitik über solche
Aktionen diskutieren heute hat der
Expertenrat für Klimafragen der
Bundesregierung ein Gutachten
vorgestellt in dem er gesagt hat dass
das was wir klimapolitisch bisher machen
nicht ausreicht es gibt aber keine
hinreichende Diskussion darüber was wir
in diesen Bereich und als Reaktion auf
diesen Bericht heute machen sollten also
heute eine inhaltliche Diskussion
sondern stattdessen diskutieren wir über
diese Aktion und das ist doch das
perfide wir erleben ja Aktionen die so
absurd sind die so gefährlich sind die
auch so extremistisch sind und abseits
von der Mitte der Gesellschaft dass sie
die Diskussion in der Gesellschaft weg
vom Thema Klima auf das Thema
Aktionismus und was für was für
Protestaktionen sind eigentlich okay
lenken und damit schadet die letzte
Generation letztendlich diesem Thema und
wenn ich das schon höre dass die
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft sei für
bestimmte Maßnahmen und die Politik sei
dagegen dann muss ich dem ganz klar
entgegentreten die Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft hat diese Politik gewählt
und in einer Demokratie muss man sich
demokratischen Wahlen stellen wir haben
in dieser Bundesregierung gerade 49 Euro
Tickets beschlossen wir haben den Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien durch das Wind an
Land gesetzt und andere Maßnahmen
vereinfacht wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
es ein früheren cola-ausstieg gibt
lassen Sie uns über all diese Maßnahmen
sprechen und das aufdröseln was da nicht
genug ist und dann gibt es da
Diskussionen im Parlament und außerhalb
des Parlaments aber auf Gewalt und auf
solche Geschichten zu setzen das wird am
Ende scheitern und es nützt dem Klima
rein gar nichts verständlicher Punkt
Herr Kuhle das ist nachvollziehbar aber
Frage an Sie ist nicht das was Frau
Rochel sagt auch nachvollziehbar da
haben nun Greta thünenberg Luisa
Neubauer diese ganzen Fridays for
Futures Demonstrationen viel
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen da sind die
Sprecher Luisa Neubauer eingeladen
worden mit Politikern zu reden und und
und man hat den jungen Menschen auf die
Schulter geklopft und gesagt jawohl das
ist alles richtig aber was ist denn
passiert um wirklich das Klima zu retten
sie selber sagen ist ja gerade UNO
klimabberichte sagen wir verfehlen die
Ziele von Paris absolut und insofern ist
es nicht auch nachvollziehbar dass ich
sag mal jetzt die Generation von Frau
Rochel jetzt sagt ja das hat alles nicht
geholfen dann müssen wir eben radikaler
werden und ein Kollege von Frau Rochel
Henning Jeschke auch ein Aktivist sagt
junge Menschen waren lange Zeit leise
wir werden das nicht tun also noch
radikaler sein um eben wirklich was zu
bewegen ist eigentlich dieser Frust auch
verständlich
Frust ist verständlich und
nachvollziehbar wenn man eine
demokratische Entscheidung trifft und am
Ende reicht einem der Kompromiss nicht
aus dann muss man diese Leute eben beim
nächsten Mal abwählen oder selber sich
zur Wahl stellen oder eine Partei
eintreten ich weiß dass das altmodisch
klingt aber es ist nun mal so wie das in
einer Demokratie organisiert wird ich
glaube auch dass das was momentan
gemacht wird von der Politik in
Deutschland Europa und auf der ganzen
Welt zu wenig ist um die Klimaziele zu
erreichen aber wir müssen doch auch
sehen dass wir aktuell einen Krieg
mitten in Europa haben Russland führt
einen Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
und das führt dazu dass die Leute in
Deutschland momentan Schwierigkeiten
haben ihre Wohnung zu heizen die wissen
nicht wie Sie Ihre Stromrechnung
bezahlen sollen die wissen nicht wie sie
in ihrem Betrieb die Gasversorgung
sicherstellen können das sind Punkte um
die sich die Politik jetzt akut kümmern
muss und gleichzeitig haben wir die
Klimakrise die wir bewältigen müssen und
wir müssen in dieser wirklich komplexen
Lage mit den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
doch in der vernünftigen Weise immer aus
bleiben und wir dürfen die
gesprächsfäden nicht abreißen lassen
indem wir sagen ich klebe mich jetzt an
der Straße fest und lass dich einfach
nicht mehr durch lass dich einfach nicht
mehr durch das ist vorbei wir
diskutieren nicht mehr darüber weil ich
habe recht und und du hast unrecht so
wird es nicht gehen wir haben eine
komplexe Lage viele Probleme jeden Tag
sterben Menschen in der Ukraine Menschen
in Deutschland wissen nicht wie sie vor
Stromrechnung bezahlen sollen und ich
weiß dass wir Gefahr laufen das auch
Menschen sterben und das auch schon
Menschen sterben weil es zu heiß wird
auf diesem Planeten das ist mir klar
aber wir müssen diese Probleme gemeinsam
in den Griff kriegen und dürfen uns
nicht durch solche Aktionen spalten
lassen als Gesellschaft das führt in die
falsche Richtung also ein klarer Appell
von Ihnen Herr Kohle ganz herzlichen
Dank wir müssen uns leider aus
Zeitgründen von ihnen verabschieden weil
sie nur bis 6:45 Uhr Zeit haben vielen
vielen Dank und wir wollen mit Ihnen
Frau Rocher einfach noch mal über die
Punkte von Herrn coole sprechen haben
aber auch hier noch ein paar Fragen und
das geht in die Richtung ein bisschen
die Kritik die Herr Kuhle
zusammengefasst hat erstens einmal da
gibt es einen Krieg es gibt momentan bei
Menschen ganz andere Sorgen stößt man
die nicht sozusagen vor den Kopf will
man das nicht irgendwie akzeptieren Nils
schreibt über Youtube wieso ist es denn
für sie spricht jetzt sie an so
unverständlich das Verhalten mit
extremistischen Zügen egal wie gut der
Grund auch sein mag zu einer breiten
gesellschaftlichen Ablehnung führt das
ist doch das normalste der Welt also was
ich schon so ein bisschen sagte ist das
nicht für sie für ihre Kolleginnen und
Kollegen denn Aktivisten verständlich
das gewisse Aktionen zu einer Ablehnung
führen man die Menschen also gar nicht
mehr mitnimmt
wir haben uns dafür entschieden weil wir
gesehen haben in der Geschichte des
ziviler Widerstand funktioniert dass
sich Menschen friedlich auf Straßen
gesetzt haben schon lange vor uns und
damit ein politischen Wandel erzeugt
haben ein gesellschaftlichen Wandel ich
erlebe auch jeden Tag wieder auf der
Straße und im Netz natürlich auch dass
uns viel Hass entgegenschlägt wir
wussten von Anfang an das ist unangenehm
wird ich sehe aber auch die Mutter mit
ihrem kleinen Kind am Rand stehen von
der Straße die sich bedankt die ihre
kleinen Tochter erzählt warum wir dort
sind und ich sehe auch Menschen die auf
uns zukommen die auch sagen ich habe
Angst dass ich meine Kinder nicht mehr
ernähren kann wir machen das nicht für
uns dort es ist nicht schön auf der
Straße zu sitzen
und Studien haben auch gezeigt dass es
Menschen nicht abstößt davon von
Klimaschutz solche Aktionen zu machen
sondern dass sie eher bereit sind an
Demonstrationen teilzunehmen an zivilen
Widerstand hält
widersprechen
widersprechen sie sich da nicht gerade
selbst sie sagen ja sie erfahren Hetze
im Internet sie sagen die Medien hetzen
da muss man dann auch fragen was meinen
Sie jetzt hätte im Internet oder meinen
Sie die Medien die Medien berichten
weitestgehend eben über die Dinge die
gesagt werden wenn die Feuerwehr
Strafanzeige gegen zwei Aktivisten
stellt dann ist das eben einfach so wenn
andere Leute in Social Media Kanälen
eben Hetze üben und sie kritisieren dann
hat das nicht ist das nicht die Medien
aber wenn ihnen ja da etwas
entgegenschlägt was sie ja nicht möchten
dann ist es ja nicht gleichzeitig so
dass sie damit dann unwahrscheinlich
viele Leute animieren aktivieren jetzt
mit Ihnen für das Klima auf die Straße
zu gehen und diese Aktion zu machen
was wir gerade sehen ist das immer mehr
Menschen dazu kommen unser Ziel ist es
nicht die Autofahrer in dort im Stau zu
überzeugen unser Ziel ist es politischen
Druck aufzubauen klarzustellen dass wir
so nicht mehr weitermachen können
und ich habe einfach unfassbare Angst
davor was passiert wenn wir das nicht
schaffen was passiert wenn wir die
Klimaziele nicht einhalten gerade geht
durch die Medien ganz locker das 1,5
Grad wahrscheinlich nichts mehr wird
aber 1,5 Grad erreichen wir bereits 2030
wir haben uns international dazu
verpflichtet das einzuhalten 1,5 Grad
oder deutlich unter zwei Grad und dass
das nicht passiert und dass die Medien
darüber nicht berichten ist fatal dass
die Medien nicht darüber ganz kurz
unterbrechen dass die Medien nicht
darüber berichten kann man glaube ich
nicht ganz so stehen lassen denn ich
habe es ja eben auch gesagt die Medien
berichten ja durchaus darüber
multiplatativ saß auch bei volle Kanne
und andere Klimaforscher auch und
berichten darüber dass diese Klimaziele
nicht eingehalten werden die Berichte
der UNO die ja selbst das äußerst
kritisch sagen dass wir nicht bei 1,5
landen sondern viel die Erwärmung für
höher sein wird das wird schlechte
Medien durchaus auch transportiert aber
die Frage ist ja ganz einfach es kommt
ja auf die Form an und es gibt zwei
Meldungen hier zwei Kommentare die ja
ganz interessant sind es gibt Alexander
die schreibt über Youtube toller Protest
es gibt genug Jobs die dringend besetzt
werden müssen Elektriker Klempner da
könnten sie aktiv für den Klimaschutz
was tun Solarmodule aufbauen
beispielsweise das würde helfen und es
gibt noch einen anderen ja lustigen aber
vielleicht auch ernst gemeinten
kommentar von Eike über Youtube die
haben nur alle nur Langeweile blockiert
nicht die Arbeitnehmer sondern Vorschlag
die Politiker auf dem Weg ins Parlament
dann bekommt ihr vielleicht Gehör ist
nicht die Frage so ein bisschen einfach
die Form wie man protestiert wen man
blockiert und wo man vielleicht dann
eben auch mehr Unterstützung erfährt von
der Allgemeinheit
wir sind auch immer wieder im
regierungsmittel wir sind immer wieder
an den Parteizentralen wir sehen aber
auch dass diesen Protest weniger
Menschen sehen
Presse und Medien interessiert das
einfach nicht so doll dauernd ist
irgendeine Demo vor dem Bundestag damit
erreicht man heute nichts mehr was wir
brauchen gerade sind unglaublich viele
Menschen auf der Straße in zivilen
Widerstand die wirklich sagen ich gehe
jetzt nicht mehr zur Arbeit ich mache
mein Studium nicht mehr weiter ich gehe
jetzt auf die Straße weil die Situation
einfach so dramatisch ist ich würde sehr
viel lieber zu Hause sitzen in meiner WG
ich würde sehr viel lieber studieren und
ich wünschte ich müsste das nicht machen
aber mir bleibt kein anderer Weg mehr
dann greifen wir von Herrn Kuhle das auf
müssten vielleicht noch mal einen
Livestream machen weil er sagt man muss
vielleicht miteinander reden um
gemeinsam weiter zu kommen und diese
Kanäle des Sprechens miteinander eben
auf auch von halten zwei Kommentare noch
always be yourself schreibt über Youtube
auch interessant die Verkehrslage beim
Dreieck Funkturm ist eigentlich immer
Stau es ist der meistbefahrenste
Abschnitt Europas wurde mal gesagt die
Fahrer sind dort nie in der Lage in der
Rettungsgasse zu bilden sieht man
tagtäglich nimmt sie ein bisschen in
Schuss dass der normale Straßenverkehr
in Berlin mehr schafft als sie mit ihren
Blockaden und Ismael 04 schreibt über
YouTube eine Frage man braucht auch die
Mehrheit beim Klimaschutz wieso wählt
ihr diese protestart denn die Leute
reden nicht mehr über Klimaschutz
sondern über die Aktionen das hilft doch
dem Klima Null also das gleiche Argument
was Herr coole sagte was sagen Sie also
wie gesagt hier schreibt Ismael das
gleiche
wie schon gesagt ich glaube die Mehrheit
für Maßnahmen Klimaschutz gibt es schon
lange in der Bevölkerung was wir aber
beobachten ist dass das Thema einfach
immer und immer wieder vom Tisch
gewischt wird das wird in irgendwelche
Beratungsgremien gesteckt irgendwo weil
es einfach unangenehm ist weil es
natürlich auch jetzt für die Politiker
in der Regierung ein großer Schritt ist
zu sagen ja wir legen jetzt los wir
müssen jetzt ins Handeln kommen und
deshalb fordern wir von der Regierung
dass solche einfachen Maßnahmen wie das
9 Euro Ticket wie ein Tempolimit auf den
Autobahnen einfach umgesetzt werden
dafür liegt es schon vor wir sind das
einzige Land in Europa wahrscheinlich
fast weltweit was kein Tempolimit hat wo
man einfach mit 300 über die Autobahn
Rasen kann und wir hatten im Sommer
schon das 9 Euro Ticket warum das nicht
fortgesetzt wird ist mir einfach ein
Rätsel sind die einfachsten Schritte und
nicht mal das kriegen wir hin
und ich möchte einfach dass wir in
Deutschland
zusammenkommen dass wir sagen wie wollen
wir die nächsten Jahre zusammen leben
wie werden wir es schaffen dass wir auch
hier dann noch genug zu essen und zu
trinken haben und das sind keine
Szenarien die irgendwie mal aufgestellt
worden sind sondern es ist das
wahrscheinlichste Szenario das auch die
Demokratie in Deutschland unter der
Klimakrise zusammenbrechen wird und was
ich möchte ist in einem Land mit einer
Demokratie leben ich möchte auch nicht
dass wir uns abschotten wenn dann
Menschen aus den ganzen Zonen die nicht
mehr bewohnbar sein werden in 10-15
Jahren nach Deutschland kommen in so
einem Land möchte ich nicht leben und
deshalb werden wir auch weiter friedlich
auf die Straße gehen deshalb werden wir
unseren Protest ausweiten wir haben auch
der Regierung ein Gespräch für nächste
Woche angeboten was hoffentlich
stattfinden wird wir möchten darüber
sprechen wie wir jetzt in dieser
Krisensituation zusammen loslegen können
und endlich aufhören leere
Versprechungen zu machen endlich
aufhören Ausreden zu finden sondern
jetzt loszulegen dann bedanken wir uns
ganz herzlich und werden auch das weiter
verfolgen und werden gerne darüber
berichten wenn es dann zu diesem
Gespräch kommt und dann eben schauen wie
dann die Reaktionen sind Carla Roche
recht herzlichen Dank dass Sie mit dabei
waren Grüße nach Berlin und ich sage
Dankeschön auch für Kommentare und
Fragen für die anregende Diskussion und
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
und ein schönes Wochenende tschüss